renault bonsoir c'est ce qu'on va faire
ouais on va parler métier on va parler
show business ont à faire de la
promotion des ventes
je ferais tu alors ça c'est bien connu
alors on va commencer avec ton nouvel
album qui s'appelle visage pâle
rencontré public le renault tour 89 et
qui a été enregistré au printemps de
bourges
il le sait ça ouais elle est d'abord
enregistré au zénith way you zénith les
chansons c'est la première fois qu'on
les jouer sur scène bondi alors ça
tournait pas bien quoi j'ai écouté j'ai
dix poubelles poubelle
ouais mais je me demandais pourquoi
savait pas été poussé à bout
ouais alors est-ce que ça ça va pas d'un
seul coup quand même arrêter les ventes
de [ __ ] de camion façon les ventes
depuis lundi camion il ya une autre
version arrêté mais à combien 450 mille
six cent cinquante mille six cent
cinquante ans ça y est quand même un
double platine depuis plusieurs mois non
parce que les deux d'avant la mistral
gagnant et morgane d'élèves ayant 2 2
ouais et puis d'un seul coup tu nous
faisais 450 en compte une visite à l
150000 ses idéaux digue à 150 civils
vous et c'est bien certifié par le snep
qui travaillent tous mais franchement tu
crois que c'est dû au q3 qui a un
tassement du phénomène rome et paris a
day d'abord adapter sa filiale t d après
ce que tu le penses ouest tu penses quoi
je pense que les gens sont énervés par
le chanteur énervant ouais tu
corresponds à une sensibilité d'une
époque
ouais t'as tout qui marche tout baigne
et tout
tu corresponds au créneau jean thème ce
que tu fais c'est de l'or est-ce que
c'est pas la qualité des choses il ya
peut-être ça aussi mais ça qui peut en
juger ouais moi les gens que j'aime et
qui m'aime vraiment ils disent que c'est
mon élan al borai moi j'en suis pas
convaincu je me dis aussi que je trouve
que c'est un oeil j'ai passé les autres
les autres étaient bien et je laime -
celui-là c'est vrai donc j'ai peut-être
tué moi envie de le défendre
ouais et puis il ya aussi le fait preuve
pour au moins 25 % que j'ai créée par
avec quasiment pas mes toiles idée de
pas faire des promesses étaient
simplement parce que tu t'es dit voilà
c'est génial j'ai signé un contrat avec
virgin jupe à un milliard huit cent
trois albums je vis sur mon bateau et
dans ma maison à outremont au québec
côté de montréal ou avignon ou à la
vigne on et puis je leur envoie les
disques par la bosse non plus s'est
passé mais on attend c'est vrai que
c'est génial site web
non franchement j'ai pas conscience ne
fait pas ça ne fait pas l'idée de te
couper du monde et j'en ai marre de ce
métier j'en ai eu marre des médias j'en
ai marre de la télé paysage audiovisuel
tel qu'il est devenu l ai marre des
journalistes en ai marre de répondre
toujours une question
j'en ai marre de vendre mes chansons
comme si c'était un produit alors qu'au
départ c'est malgré tout ça reste une
oeuvre quelque chose oeuvre
une oeuvre d'art pas se sentir magique
lessive mais c'est de la création quoi
et puis d'excès sur indices c'était un
produit des tu dois toi même à les
vendre en radio achèvement dernier album
le voilà il ébauche une meilleur jeu
plus grand je lui fais le scénith le but
en blanc et tout ça je voulais plus
jouer ce jeu là ça mais ça me gonfle et
j'ai craqué dans les bars étaient leurs
apprête à 10 ans même bon mais je me
suis planté
c'était un peu comme si j'avais dit je
vais me suicider je voulais pas mourir
connu voilà j'ai dit je veux plus que
les gens connaissent les chansons
j'avais oublié la dimension d'abord
d'information des médias pour dire aux
gens mon disque est sorti mes chansons
je chante dans votre ville ce soir
ouais et puis j'avais surtout oublier
qu' il ya des gens qui même rythme le
disque était d'abord qu'on a envie de me
voir chez sabatier est obligé d'y aller
ouais mais j'ai du coup je suis quand
même chez ce monsieur je suis pas les
chirurgies rien fait sur la vie dure là
où ça a été le flip ou pas me le dire
c'est quand j'ai lu l'histoire du génie
parce qu'encore le dise pourrissement il
se rend pas mais il agit seul coup quand
on nage en ta vie je pense que c'est à
reprendre la veille quand il a dit mon
pote cet amuse de chanter devant une une
salle vide
la tétine ans la muse pas du tout ça
amuse pas d'autant que j'avais prévu de
faire un beau zénith avec un beau
spectacle avec un autre état que ça
coûte cher
quand on m'a dit spectacle coûte un
milliard et 3 milliards de recettes pour
l'amortir elle payé tout le monde avant
même que je gagnais un sentiment que le
producteur et centimes a fait un rapide
calcul il fallait cent mille spectateurs
alors sans faire télé sans en parler aux
gens sans aller dans les journaux dans
les radios passées et celles en clair
c'est impossible aussi aussi grand soit
tu cela dit bon je vais pas tenir le
discours de chez à aujourd'hui
mais bon j'ai dit ça c'est finalement ça
c'est pas si mal passé aux armes
j'ai fait cent mille lieues de faleyras
20000 d'avis le sang d'après midi la
fois d'avant ouais c'est pas mal pas mal
il ya des mecs qui font trois semaines
en ce moment et quoique quand les 70000
t'attraper coup comment elle a pris la
sortie la tablette qooq maman je suis
parti en tournée
wel gp de trois interviews dans deux ou
trois journaux que j'aimais bien fait
j'ai décidé de faire la promo choir
promotion archi sélective de faire les
émissions de gens que j'aime bien voir
de faire les interviews dans les
journaux que j'aime bien lire tout comme
ça c'est pas de la première défaite
professionnels non mais prévient bah oui
apparemment